[Applause]
okay we're on the Internet you think
switch Allah this is for you you think
Switzerland has the best health care
system in the world how do they control
costs without controlling profit well it
is their system first of all yes it's
kind of a hybrid it's well the Swiss
system is actually a lot like what the
Obamacare insurance subsidized insurance
exchanges are like and it's a lot like
what Paul Ryan proposed for Medicare
reforms where you get a subsidy to shop
for an insurance plan where the market
is defined by the government the
government defines what the insurance
plan has to look like and then you get a
subsidy depending on how wealthy you are
or how healthy or sick you watch case in
Switzerland it would be all well know
they say oh so some people are still
poor in Switzerland or lower income and
they get a bigger Samsa to really be
comparing Switzerland of a country of
how many six million that's like it's
seven million or seven and and almost
all of them don't have Swiss citizenship
you know that most of them are guessed
right I know I ever been to summit but
you know economics are economic second
out the laws of economics don't
magically get suspended when you go to
Switzerland no but the laws of economics
do change if you're talking about a
country of seven million with no poor
people versus a country of 300 million
with lots of poor look I would say that
I would say that that in terms of you
know how healthy the Swiss are the fact
they hike up mountains and ski down them
yeah we don't really do that but in
terms of the way they organize their
health insurance again Obama cares
exchange of the same way if we applied
that system broadly to the Medicare
population to the Medicaid population
what that would do is it allow us to
spend more money on the poor we'd
actually have a better program than
Medicaid today because we'd pay doctors
more pay hospitals more to take care of
the poor and we wouldn't subsidize
health care for the wealthy right now
our taxes go to subsidize government
sponsored health insurance from Mitt
Romney and Arianna Huffington and you
know Warren Buffett why should why
should we be spending money to give
people government health insurance that
can afford to buy health insurance for
themselves I don't know when you say we
give more to the doctors in hospitals
I'm not sure that's going to trickle
down you know last week we're talking
about Steven brillz article and Time
magazine
where he said you know hottie we did a
liner I like study of it you know and
they're charging fifty five dollars for
a niacin tablet sure cetera okay how
cool do a lot of terrible stuff and that
and and and and a universal system would
help what help deal with that login to
the rights couches the point that you
made about the Swiss hiking and eating
food that's not as processed and full of
sugar and all the stuff that you're
mentioning in your editorial I mean that
makes a difference in the kind of health
care system you have and that's really a
change I broke my ankle in Australia and
they allow your friends to bring you
beer saving the hospital to charge and
that's a true story what's bringing in
break your ankle a whiskey Wayne and
ambulance seems to have universal health
code are you sure do yeah I mean but a
mere the beer I get in the hospitals is
ridiculously overpriced exactly and
watery two hundred st. Paul is good the
point is that there's market oriented
ways to have universal coverage and
conservatives should get over this idea
that universal coverage is bad you know
were the wealthiest country in the world
we can easily afford to cover everyone
and we can do it in a way that's more
attune to our values consumer choice you
know we can do that yeah yes we can
all right David Cross do you think the
Twitter release of your movie has
forever changed the future of film
distribution um sure
what's up tell them what it was a
soaring as a as a joke there's a movie
coming out called it's a it's a disaster
which is a video on demand coming on the
theaters on April 12th but they put it
on vine the six-second ship thing and it
was kind of meant as a joke
well obviously Mendes adieu and but a
lot of people Hollywood Reporter I think
and the number places picked it up as a
real legitimate thing like as if that's
going you can release a movie in six
second gifts there's some dumb people
there's some really really since yes
it'll change um but it was all organic a
locally sourced success beginning every
six seconds you go six seconds yes a
fairy comes gives me a penny there you
go
Arianna what do you think the question
says is the most important issue
concerning women in 2013 as a spokesman
for all women and all women do look up
to you that's true folks women's are all
the most important what is their most
important I think the most important
issues and that we touched a little bit
in the show which is women have to lead
the way to redefine what success is and
that also goes back a little bit to your
early question about the happiness
versus greed versus the stock market
because we now have two metrics of
success you know money and power and
that's not enough because it should be a
third metric which is our own well-being
your court isn't of happiness exactly
like how healthy are you how fulfilled
are you how meaningful is your life I
mean for me if you have the corner
office in billions of dollars and you
have a heart attack in your fifties
because you are working around the clock
and you don't take care of yourself is
that success I think the most important
issue concerning women is air I I think
it's all about and men too I would say
the air
you know yes err that stuff you need to
breathe you know global warming the
water that's getting polluted yeah my
wife hates when I breathe ha ha ha
there you go again
okay final question Michael still why
should we expect any rebranding of the
GOP to benefit anyone but the GOP well
you could say that about any party yeah
you can say that about anybody but I
think the rebranding for the parties is
is important otherwise it becomes more
irrelevant than it is right now and I
think that the fact of the matter is
that the political grounds have shifted
the leadership is is stuck in a time
warp of of thinking that America will
come back to it because they don't like
what they see out on this scary plane
either it's Barack Obama words you know
mandated health care without having to
make a cogent argument without having to
understand that America is much more
black and brown than it ever has been in
it seems like they when you were the
chairman when they made you the chairman
of the party that was rebranding and
then they wanted to Unruh Brett exactly
and they're like whoa you know that's
not who we are for the party of old
white guys this is false advertising
what I'm finding yeah brandy or
anything's just branding just a brand
it's called substance it but the
branding you're right ultimately you've
got to get to substance there's no doubt
about it but the branding is the way you
begin the conversation is to make that
attraction to get people to focus on
what you're about to say well since its
Women's Day since its Women's Day
seventy-five percent of the country more
or less is white seventy-five percent of
the voters more or less as white and 40%
of all voters are white women as time
Republicans started talking to their
daughters don't come up with some crazy
abortion [ __ ] every four years
marry people vote Republican single
people vote Democrat and there are more
single people and less married people
that's part of the dumb and they
shouldn't give up on black people black
people are conservative concern and
that's but that's exactly the point when
you have an attitude that says they
won't vote for us so why bother or you
do they do what we see now where you
take a Marco Rubio you take someone you
put them out in front let's see we have
one two that is not it what is he that
is not that is not what America is
looking for they're looking for the
substance and they're looking for the
party in this leadership to understand
how we're changing and you know look for
two years for that one brief shining
moment the we were able to have a
conversation we will begin we had the
opportunity to expand we've contracted
sensing that we've got to go for it
otherwise we go you know like the wigs
okay thank you very much panel Thank You
audience we'll see you next week
real time we do more exciting I teach in
massive building his guest to a
questions right after the show at
hbo.com